Busco anuncia que ha culminado su
retirada de la ciudad estratégica de
garzón en el sur de Ucrania mientras las
fuerzas ucranianas siguen avanzando
hacia el sur por ciento encontrando
Campos llenos de minas abandonados por
los rusos
Moscú asegura que incluso ha conseguido
completar con éxito La retirada de la
margen occidental del río niepero unas
afirmaciones que no cuadran con lo que
ha dicho Ucrania en las últimas horas
los servicios de inteligencia ucranianos
aseguran que las tropas rusas siguen
dentro de gerson y que pueden tardar
incluso semanas en abandonarlos estimaba
en hasta 40.000 el número de soldados
rusos que estaban defendiendo esa
importante Plaza estratégica para
Vladimir